okay it's Thursday meaning we have the
latest jobs numbers plus we have updated
first quarter GDP numbers it's all
pretty ugly but I will sort of mention
at least a few possibly less than
horrifying components to some of this
data
first of all GDP you might remember that
about a month ago we got the first
quarter GDP estimate which was a decline
of 4.8% it's now been updated often in
the 30 days after the estimate we get an
updated GDP number the first quarter GDP
number has been made worse by being
increased to a 5% shrinking of gross
domestic product during the first
quarter now in a moment well actually
not in a moment right now the white
house is a planning not to release
expectations for the second quarter and
this is a part of the proactive
propaganda attempt to cover up
historically unconscionably bad economic
numbers that we are going to get at the
end of July and into the end of August
during into the end of August about the
second quarter the white house clearly
seeing the writing on the wall and they
are not going to be publicizing these
expectations they will get them from
their economic teams but they will not
be publicizing them and the numbers for
GDP for the first quarter getting worse
from 4.8% down to 5% down a sign of what
is to come
now jobs numbers last week another 2.1
million people lost their jobs new
unemployment claims last week 2.1
million
new unemployment unemployment claims now
understand that before coronavirus
700,000 job losses in a week was the
record I believe it was sometimes in
some time in the 80s I don't remember if
it was 82 or 88 I've mentioned it before
but losing 700,000 jobs in a week was
the record for the United States we've
now had about 10 consecutive weeks of
anywhere from three to ten times those
numbers ten consecutive weeks so we now
have first couple weeks it was about six
million jobs lost each week than five
million then around four million jobs
for a couple of weeks then
lost three million jobs a week for a
couple weeks and in total 41 million new
unemployment claims have been made
during the era of coronavirus the last
10 weeks remember that before
coronavirus we estimated the labor force
was about a hundred and fifty eight
million people so that means that 26
percent of the total workforce in ten
weeks lost their jobs insane
unimaginable economic destruction now a
few things to bear in mind this doesn't
mean that now 41 million people are
still out of work some of the people who
lost their jobs you know nine weeks ago
ten weeks ago they've gotten new jobs
and in fact if you look at continued
claims ongoing unemployment claims it
actually has come down so two weeks ago
we were at 25 million active unemployed
people that is now down to 21 million so
that's something it means that in the
last week more people got off of
unemployment than the number that got on
the most likely scenario based on these
numbers is that we are going to see very
high unemployment numbers for a very
long time even if every state was able
to reopen today to 75 percent you would
still see very big numbers continuing
certainly into 2021 and there are
questions about could this be you know a
two year recovery could this be a five
year recovery we just don't know but the
point is forget about this being fixed
to any significant degree before the
November election
and this is why yesterday's segment
about garbage math is so important
because there's a good chance that after
disastrous second quarter numbers we
will start to see some improvement from
these absolutely you know bottom bottom
bottom lows in the third quarter and as
we start to see that recovery in the
third quarter hopefully if we just
continue straight on if wave one and
wave 2 blend together and things
continue to worsen this may not happen
but if you start to see some improvement
in the third quarter the administration
is going to start to focus on growth
rates I already told you now they're
floating air travel reservations are up
a hundred and
20 percent well yeah but they were down
to just four percent right they were
down 96 percent they are now recovering
from being only four percent of what
they were so the base rate matters we've
talked before yesterday about how this
will impact propaganda around GDP
numbers propaganda around jobs and
unemployment numbers so I want things to
improve as rapidly as possible but I
also don't want to get bamboozled into
thinking that things are better than
they actually are nor into being
bamboozled into believing that Donald
Trump fixed something that he actually
had nothing to do with so the numbers
are clearly going to keep getting worse
before they get better including in the
quarter we're currently in the second
quarter we won't know how bad it got
this quarter until around August first
or even September first the official
dates for q2 GDP are estimate I believe
on July 30 and update on August 30 so be
prepared be prepared is the point and
don't fall for garbage math as we will
undoubtedly be subjected to by this
administration one of our sponsors is
privacy calm they're giving you $5 when
you sign up for their completely free
service at privacy calm slash Pakman
I've been using privacy for a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before it's a lifesaver and
here's how it works takes just a couple
of minutes to set up anytime you buy
something online or on the phone instead
of actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app and the browser
plugin let you give each company a
randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click and the payment is taken out of
your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to twelve of these virtual
credit cards a month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them any time you want so
when you do this it means you're not
going to be charged when you don't want
to be because you can destroy the
virtual card number right after using
which for instance I love using free
trials because I know I won't be charged
when the trial is over if I use a
virtual credit card number you're
keeping your identity private by not
telling companies who you are you're
keeping your bank or credit card info
protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a $10 a month plan that
gives you one percent cashback and lets
you create 36 credit cards a month and a
$25 a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm / Pakman